the onyx logic metagenomics program will  be starting very soon in this online  program we will explore the amazing role  microbes play in the environment human  health and disease program will cover  the main aspects of microbiome studies  using metagenomic sequencing analysis of  microbiome composition and species  richness as well as other aspects of  microbiology research using  bioinformatics  during this program you will also have  the opportunity to apply bioinformatics  analysis methods  to research projects analyzing data from  the public domain and learning from high  impact biomedical publications on  relevant topics so in this program we  will discuss how  the 16s ribosomal rna gene amplicon  studies hypervariable region  amplification or even whole metagenomic  sequencing and even metatranscriptome  studies are revealing the significance  of microorganisms  all around